so here's my morning routine I wake up
every morning to the Sun of bird
chirping and the lights from a clock I
can't take the sound of a normal alarm
clock because it always gives me a shock
the first thing in the morning when I
get up is to check my phone
I'll check through my messages Facebook
Instagram and read through your comments
it puts a smile on my face in the
morning once I'm out of bed I like to
open my curtains really wide to look out
and just allow the Morning Sun to shine
in then it's my daily Moni toilet visit
to pee and flush out all the water from
the night before I always wake up to a
really full bladder time to brush my
teeth and cleanse my face at the moment
I'm still using the foam cleanser by
Lynette as it is very gentle on my acne
prone skin since I've been back in
Malaysia my skin has been acting up due
to the heat and air pollution in kuala
lumpur so i've started using Clarisonic
for a deeper cleanse once a day in the
morning if you happen to use this
product you will know that it can get
pretty costly to replace the brush heads
every three months but the great thing
is a friend introduced me to a
compatible replacement brush heads by
position so it is available on Amazon
with lots of positive reviews so I've
used the originals and the position ones
are just as good it lifts my skin really
soft and smooth and it is extremely
gentle on my acne prone skin my
precision brush heads only costs $15 for
a set of 2 instead of $27 for each of
the Clarisonic brand so I've placed the
links to the product in my description
box for you guys to check out now that
I'm feeling fresh and awake my most
important morning ritual is
to walk out to my balcony and just spend
five minutes on my own this is the time
where I'll count my blessings give
thanks for my family friends you guys
and all that I have and just remind
myself to not take anything for granted
in life it is my quiet moment to just
breathe and connect with my heart then
I'll head to the kitchen and drink this
entire bottle to keep myself hydrated
I'll put the kettle on and make myself a
pot of green tea I tend to sleep through
the entire pot of green tea while going
on my laptop to read your comments and
reply to as many as I can while
depending on my schedule I don't get to
do this every morning although I really
wish I could reply to all of you
personally this is also when I'll write
down my things to accomplish for the day
it helps to keep me focused and
organized then I'll head to the kitchen
again and have my breakfast or
pre-workout meal so I like to keep it
rather light nowadays I've been hooked
on oats especially my favourite sloppy
overnight oatmeal so I made this bowl
the night before and it is really
convenient especially on my busy
mornings I've mixed it with half a cup
of milk 1 tablespoon of goji berries and
1 TSP of chair seeds topped with mango
cubes yummy time to get change into my
workout clothes and hit the gym my
activewear is by my own clothing line
fit and feminine do check it out and you
can shop my food collection in the link
below I tend to do my workouts in my
dream apartment for about 45 to 60
minutes depending on my routine for the
day so today it's total body circuit
training 6 exercises 5 sets in 30
minutes so it is a short and intense and
I like to wear my polyhedron monitor to
keep track of my training progress after
the really sweaty session I'll head back
and take a shower on a normal day
I'm usually dressed in my jean skirt and
casual top after my shower and while
waiting for my hair
drei because I do not like to use the
hairdryer too often that's when I'll
make my post-workout snack green
smoothie so one cup of frozen banana
sliced one cup of green leafy vegetable
half a cup of milk half a cup of water
and 1 tablespoon of goji berries blend
it up cheers guys okay time for my
skincare routine so at the moment I'm
using two brands Lynette and herb a line
which uses all natural ingredients so
I'll start by spraying the soothing
toner by Herbalife then apply the water
bang essence by Lynette then the aloe
vera gel by herb a line to heal any
marks and scars then hydrate my skin
with the water Bank gel cream by Lynette
and finally apply the sunscreen by her
Beuerlein gosh this used to be such a
hassle because I am a wash and go type
of girl but I am seeing the results and
slowly getting used to the routine so on
a normal day I don't really apply any
makeup on except a little bit of shading
on my eyebrows black eye shadows and
just to make my tiny eyes a tiny bit
bigger and a really light lipstick I
like to keep my face natural and fresh
now it's time to deal with my
out-of-control short hair well I'm sure
you notice that at the left side of my
hair is behaving really well however the
right side is just curling outwards and
it looks really weird the guys at NUMMI
actually noticed my short hair issue and
they were kind enough to introduce me to
the argan oil and curl jam set which
came with the curly one and fashionista
flat iron so I start by applying just a
little bit of argan oil on my hair I
love the smell of this oil and it keeps
my hair really soft and smooth so it
works as an anti-frizz serum heat
protectant and it also adds shine to my
hair and to be honest I do like it when
I get compliments on how healthy and
shiny
my hair looks whenever I go out after
using this so to keep my hair under
control I use the new me fashionista
flat iron I've had previous experiences
where I damaged my hair with other
heated flat irons this flat iron doesn't
take the moist out of my hair keeping it
healthy shiny and damage free and using
this I don't have to run my hair through
the plates that many times so it's quick
and it keeps my hair straight for the
entire day the gas a new me is offering
great discounts for their products use
the code pretty and fit to get 40% off
of the entire new me website plus free
us shipping use the code sweat and style
to get at the curl gem set that I use or
any styling said for $100 off plus free
argan oil with every purchase so see my
description box for links and discount
codes now that I'm ready it's time to
get some work done while depending on my
list for the day it can either be an
editing day planning or filming a new
video or having meetings outside today
is a relaxing day so I'm going to do my
edits and work from home although
sometimes I do prefer to work from a
cafe I'll also log on to my fit and
feminine active website to check your
orders get them packed and shipped off
so guys that's basically my morning
routine but then again every day is
slightly different do check out the
description box below for links to
products I like and use what's your
morning routine let me know in the
comments below all the best for new
Fitness food and motivational videos
please like share and subscribe to my
youtube channel and website do follow me
on Facebook Instagram and Twitter to
stay connected with me thanks guys
you